Yehuda is with us in Baltimore hey yo
what's up hey how's it going better than
I deserve
how can I help good good question for
you I know you're not a fan of having a
credit card I've heard you say that many
times I was just wondering how is
someone someone's will to build credit
without using credit cards why would you
want to build credit so don't need
credit to get a mortgage oh so you're
gonna go in debt okay actually you don't
well to get a mortgage
no why if you could get a mortgage
without building credit what why else
would you build credit can you get a
mortgage without building credit yeah
I'll tell you how in a minute but if you
could get a mortgage without building
credit and you had a zero credit score
is there any other reason you would want
to build credit not particularly
okay because really the the the thing of
building credit is a thing invented by
the banks because basically it works
like this I'm gonna go into debt why so
I can build credit why so I can go into
debt why so I can build credit why so I
can go into debt why so I can build
credit why because I just love banks you
know that's really what the whole
society is turned into if you think
about it and so you can get a mortgage
with a zero credit score if you go to a
mortgage company like Churchill mortgage
that does what's called or was willing
to do what's called manual underwriting
which means they verify your job they
verify your income they verify your
savings position and they'll verify that
you paid your landlord early or on time
and with zero credit score you can get
the same interest rate the same mortgage
as someone without but you have to have
a mortgage company that knows how to and
is willing to go to the trouble it's
extra trouble for them to do manual
underwriting in Churchill mortgages one
of them that will do that we endorse
Churchill and we love them and that's
what we'd recommend avoiding debt